all right let's go to lisa in little
rock lisa what's happening
hi um i want to express my gratitude for
the difference the organization based on
being the other personality
i've grown into adulthood
um i'm 56 but it probably took me till i
was 40 to start growing up and those
rooms
helped me on that journey thank you so
much lisa how can we help
i'm calling today because um
we're getting ready to do a will it's
been long overdue
we have a son that is a nerdy well
and we don't want to fund stupid and
he's got two children the oldest is
maybe 12 that we've
never met and we and they're being
raised
in stupid today i knew it was coming
but today i found out in writing that i
have been disinherited
um my father was very abusive and i
walked away seven years ago
i don't want our son to feel
like i feel even though i knew i did the
right thing
i don't know if i can have those things
sometimes we can't have those things
but i wanted to know is it
how do you honorably not leave an
inheritance
to your children um and then should i
just skip a generation
set up like a college fund for his
children not a college fund a fund for
his children
and if they're flying straight if
they're doing well
we pay for a semester of college and if
they're not it reverts to somewhere else
i want to be honorable so i think the
person you need to be honorable to
first is you and the person you need to
be honorable first too is you and your
husband and what your decision is going
to be about
your money and your legacy and your
investment and whoever's future
and my husband's perfectly fine was not
not being unkind but not leaving
anything to him i'm the one
with this new experience and why do you
not want to leave him with something
again because you said he's doing stupid
yeah how old is yours he's been stupid
his whole life yeah how old is he
how old is he 30 36 okay
what's a what's a conversation with him
like these days
are y'all in contact at all there is
none he he he doesn't answer the phone
okay about once every two years he'll
call my husband say hi
okay and why does he not talk to you
anymore
i was the stepmom okay and as soon as he
was old enough to
leave the house he he chose his mother
she had a more relaxed i was she had
she didn't have a schedule she didn't
have a home routine
and we did and i was too strict in
keeping it with all my children
but with him being the step child he
really didn't need that
and um so he left at 16 okay
and he kind of he kind of turned his
back on us
but i did i turned my back on my father
but we didn't abuse him
well yeah it's a very different
situation and so you're projecting your
pain onto him you're projecting your
hurt into a
totally different situation and so what
you do
yeah your pain is very different than
his and what you need to do is get with
your husband and feel very good about
your legacy
and you need to do what's right by you
and what y'all want to do
your son your step son doesn't have a
automatic right to your money
no wait wait wait we're going to talk
about this after the break all right how
about this let's hang on let's hang on
this is got something to say about this
all right let's hang out and lisa i want
you to know something
off the air me and anthony had some good
discussions and we are in complete
disagreement on
moving forward for you sir are you ready
for us to hash this out with you
well here's my thing i i don't disagree
that the state that your son is in right
now
that he doesn't deserve anything
here's where i disagree at that he still
needs to be in the will
but he needs to be in the will from his
father and you
with stipulations that um
and i think you put in the wheel very
clearly
here are the stipulations and when you
all put that in the wheel
you somehow try to reach out to your son
whether that's via a letter
whether that's via a phone call and let
him know hey
we want a community we want to
communicate with you
we want to have a relationship with you
and son
you know we want this before you know we
transition and go off to heaven
and so if if you can honor that we will
honor you in our will but if you cannot
honor that
and if you cannot respect us then you
wouldn't you will not receive
anything from our transition so
i'm saying have stipulations in the will
that says if this is met if if here's
something for the kids
if my son does xyz or da da da da
whatever that is that you and your
husband can agree upon
leave him with something because here's
why and here's the truth
you know um
i believe that life can change in the
next
three months two years we don't know
what
can happen and so if we can give him the
possibility for
change i believe we speak what we seek
hoping that we will see what we spoke
and i believe that if your son
hears you all's heart receives a letter
from you and he and his father say hey
we are preparing for this day and but
before then
we want a relationship with you we want
a relationship with our grandchildren
and we want to honor you but we feel
we feel obligated that we cannot bless
stup stupid but we can bless
honor does that make sense he does
and we don't really even require that
he come around much or call much we just
don't want to be stupid with his money
i understand he's a little boy whose
parents got divorced and his dad got
remarried
he is hurting to this day and
but we don't need if i'm stupid and i
learned that from you all
yeah you know and here's the thing too
and i may say this and yeah yeah y'all
may not like me after this show and
that's fine i'll let you know oh i
like you i might agree with you yeah
okay um
i think you're i think your husband
needs to step up more
i think that your husband needs to step
up and say hey son
i know what happened years ago
probably hurt you let's talk about it if
you need to cuss me out cuss me out if
you need to scream scream if you need to
cry
cry let's let's be two grown men
and let's hash this out let me know
how i hurt you um how it impacted you
and then let's talk it out and if you're
scared do it with this us two
let's sit down with some let's call into
the doctor john de lane's show
and and get some counseling to help this
out because i think it's the father's
responsibility
somewhat i'm not saying all but i'm
saying somewhat to reach out and say son
let's fix this and then i think
he will have a peace if your son stays
in a stupid mindset
stays in this whole i don't i don't care
about you all then i
i would have a peace as a father saying
i reached out i wrote a letter i
even put stipulations inside my will i'm
going to heaven with a
peaceful mind saying that i tried to
leave a legacy i tried to give my son
something
but my son refused the last thing i want
on your heart or on your husband's heart
is
did we really try everything that we
should have tried
to build that relationship right yeah
i can live i can completely respect that
and so i'm going to say that anthony are
much closer than i thought we were
during the break
i mean okay good i are
he said it in a in a more eloquent way
your values are your values and your
money is your money
correct and so in a very similar vein
it's up to you and your husband to
decide what are the stipulations and
who's going to be the beneficiary
i'm with anthony in this i'm going to go
to the ends of the earth yeah
i'm gonna mine the depths of hell for my
son yeah
i'm gonna get teary just saying those
words right here on the show
yeah and i'm i also know i've worked
with too many people
hundreds and thousands over the years
who their kids just walk away
right and so i don't want the parent
listening to this i don't want your
husband listening to this for him to
have his hands
around his face and him saying i have
and my kid keeps walking away
so it's a both end you know what i mean
right
it's your money choices and not free
agency that's right it's your values
and i'm with anthony i don't want to die
without my son holding the letter with
him knowing how much i love him yeah
i don't want my stepson to die i don't
want me to die without my stepson
knowing
how much i put in to get him on the
phone to get in his grandkids life
every single chance i could and i also
don't want to take you to take your pain
you did a hard thing you walked away
from an abusive father
you broke free and it's going to cost
you financially but your your soul is
going to be lighter
yeah very great well my chill already is
i'll tell you what i did
i knew this was coming it's a little
it's a little shocking to see it writing
i knew this was coming but i have a
relationship with jesus christ
and so i have dove in immersed
myself in in sources
to teach me about my eternal inheritance
from my
heavenly father and it just really hopes
um christ is there crying with me as he
laughs with me
and he is walking me through this and
then surrounding myself with
people who teach wisdom
um i'm okay but it's just shocking
to see it there and i didn't want to
make the same mistake with
my totally different pains in totally
different situations that look very
okay okay okay but i i can accept that i
can accept that
and we can sit down and we can get this
done i love it lisa
you if you have helped a chunk of people
across this country today so i want to
thank you for your openness and your
vulnerability
absolutely and for joining us yeah and i
want to thank you for spurning a great
conversation with me and my friend here
yeah as we wrap our heads around how do
you how do you honor somebody
how do you protect them from themselves
how do you do right by your money
and how do you go the beyond the extra
mile
to let your kids know however old they
are 5
25 36 46 that i love you more than life
itself and i'm going to keep chasing and
i'm going to keep pursuing you and keep
pursuing you
and you know what too man
we can finish this here let's let's end
the show like this
even if my son never came around i would
still leave my son with something man
i would do because i believe in the word
grace
and how often do we as individuals have
grace when we don't deserve it
and i think sometimes that grace when we
don't deserve it it's the same thing
that made us
change our life and i think if i left my
son
something with a very detailed letter
saying
why i left this even though you didn't
deserve this
but because i loved you more than you
treated me
we never know what kind of impact that
could have
on his life or her life whoever it is
that's exactly right
where i've seen parents struggle is when
they know their kid is an addict
yeah when they know their kid has some
dangerous habits
yeah and they understand that putting a
hundred thousand dollars in the account
it may hurt somebody yeah right yeah and
so i get that
that parental tension that's different
than someone you know
uses language i don't like right that so
but it's a hard thing and it's attention
it's something that every one of us is
going to have to grapple with right
right